welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the mandalorian season 2 finale
broke our hearts with the bittersweet
return
of luke skywalker a jedi master at the
peak of his skill set so why shouldn't
we trust the child grogu to his care
and training oh right his school burns
down and all of his students die
our delight at seeing luke at his best
was abruptly cut by
our fear of what we all know will be his
worst and despite
mando telling grogu don't be afraid
and fear being the path of the dark side
and all that since the events of the
sequel trilogy now lie ahead of these
characters
we have to ask did kylo ren kill grogu
[Music]
let's break down the timeline to answer
this question the mandalorian is set at
9 aby that is five years after return of
the jedi for aby
and 25 years before the force awakens 34
aby
kylo ren was born as ben solo in 5 aby
so during the mandalorian ben solo is a
four-year-old with his mother leia
organa luke will not begin
training ben until he is 10 years old in
aby about six years from now that is
when luke builds a new jedi temple and
begins training ben alongside a dozen
other students as he explained in the
last jedi
i took him a dozen students
and began a training temple that was
until 28
aby when luke confronted ben over his
suspicion of the dark side rising in his
nephew
a confrontation that freaked out ben and
ben reacted violently
when i came to the temple was burning he
had vanished with a handful of my
students
and slaughtered the rest this would
suggest that grogu
if he was still with luke skywalker at
this time
was either killed by ben solo or he
somehow fled
but here's the problem with that grogu
is 50 years old during the mandalorian
so at the time of ben's temple massacre
he would be 78
this species ages slowly so he would
still be in the early stages of his life
but
we also know that yoda became a jedi
master
by age 100. that would imply a period of
rapid maturation between ages 50 and 100
for grogu
at age 78 he's probably gonna be
something close to a fully functioning
adult
at luke's training temple he would be
kind of like the ta who probably knows a
lot more than the professor
blah blah blah let the old man talk i'll
clear it up for you in the lab
also who wants some extra credit yeah i
had to flirt with a lot of tas to
graduate anyway i don't think a freaked
out
kid like ben solo as powerful as he
might be
would be able to take grogu at that
point and again if grogu was even there
i don't think grogu would
just save himself and then let ben solo
run off like that furthermore
accompanying literature
showed how ben's temple attack was far
less of the deliberate systematic
slaughter of jedi that anakin skywalker
executed under order 66
ben's turn was far more complicated see
in the comic miniseries the rise of kylo
ren
ben's dark side powers come to him as a
complete surprise
his anger brings in dark storm clouds
over the temple
lightning strikes causing the fire that
kills most of the students inside
ben even tries to run into the temple to
save whoever's in there but another
lightning bolt blows him back
and then the mysterious voice in his
head said that all their deaths are
luke's fault that voice being snoke well
actually according to the rise of
skywalker the voice is palpatine
whatever
but then three other jedi students named
beau hennix and tai
return from some other mission and they
see that the temple's on fire they asked
ben what happened
he snaps that luke tried to kill him
this is all luke's fault the order was a
lie
it's done they all argue it leads to
this tense pursuit
those three were the handful of students
that luke mentioned to rey
then loses them in the chase he meets
snoke on a space station
and then ben reconnects with ren leader
of a gang that once confronted a younger
ben
and luke and lor santeka and then those
three jedi catch up to ben
through a series of conflicts henniks
gets killed by his own blade
ty gets killed by ren and then ben kills
ren
and then kills bo his longtime rival at
the temple and he takes over
ren's gang proclaiming himself kylo ren
and then he cracks his kyber crystal
bleeds his rage into it
causing his new lightsaber to burn a
fiery red
so knowing this to be kylo ren's journey
during that period
where would that leave grogu but before
i continue this video is sponsored by
crunchyroll
crunchyroll is the world's largest
destination for anime and manga their
crunchyroll premium subscription offers
unlimited anime manga and drama titles
all professionally subtitled in
free and 1080p they have more than 90
of all officially licensed anime content
in the world and you can access it on
all of your devices like xbox
playstation apple tv and they've got all
the best titles like my hero academia
one piece attack
on titan if you're new to anime or a
more casual viewer attack on titan is a
great place to jump in
it's a dark action fantasy show with
great characters
an insane concept their last season
premiered at the same time as the final
season the game of thrones and uh let's
just say
a lot of us prefer an attack on titan
they're offering a 14-day free trial to
our fans so click on the link in the
description
and give it a run a naruto run if you
will binge watch your butt off and fall
in love with the most authentic anime
experience you can find outside of japan
they even simulcast some new episodes an
hour after they air in japan so just go
to crunchyroll.com
new rockstars or click on the link in
the description and get your 14 day
pre-trial
of crunchyroll premium now that is
crunchyroll.comrockstars and leave a
comment below and let me know what
titles i should be checking out on
crunchyroll okay i think we can conclude
that ben solo would not have been in a
place to kill grogu on the night of his
departure
from luke and the temple he was not yet
kylo ren
and it was hard enough for him to kill
those three other jedi students to turn
the dark side i also find it highly
unlikely that lucasfilm is going to
reveal that groku was just
one of the jedi who died inside a
burning temple not only would a
lightning-induced house fire be a pretty
unceremonious way to go for one of the
most beloved star wars characters
we saw in chapter 8 that grogu as a baby
was perfectly capable of force pushing
back
a wall of flames he would have no
trouble escaping that burning temple if
he was in it and based on all this
evidence i consider it
doubtful that grogu's fate would have
anything to do with ben solo's revolt
and i also believe that grogu will be
long
gone from luke skywalker's history by
the time luke
builds the temple and begins training
ben as 15 aby so yeah all these bits
about t.a grogu
probably never going to happen because
i'm facing this on the fact that there
was no
mention of grogu at the temple in any of
ben's early years there
roku at least would have been a prized
student
a big man on campus but like grosgu's
time at the jedi temple on coruscant
it's extremely telling that jedi like
ahsoka had no idea of grogu's existence
despite them being contemporaries at
that school
so we got six years to account for with
grogu
and luke between 9 aby and 15 aby when
the temple begins
this one-on-one training period would
have transpired during what we
previously called luke's search for
knowledge period
traveling from planet to planet to learn
about the history of the jedi and the
sith
and now we know grogu will join him on
part of that journey grogu might visit
och2
a planet that we can assume luke has
already found based on his discovery of
the holocron star map and battlefront 2
campaign which is set far
earlier than the mandalorian also the
fact that luke could have been
at those temple ruins when grogu pinged
him from tython
maybe he'll get an adorable training
montage in which grogu piggybacks on
luke the way yoda did on dagobah but no
matter what i think the most logical
move
is a time jump to the other side of
grogu's time with luke at least that's
what this star wars saga has normally
done to show the passage of time with
jedi training like with anakin and the
prequels and luke between empire strikes
back and return to jedi now you're gonna
say the exception was ahsoka tano whose
jedi training did go down relatively in
real time throughout the many years of
clone wars series
but even ahsoka disappeared for a bit
and then just popped back up in rebels
as a more mature badass
the version of her we know in the
mandalorian and i doubt lucasfilm is
gonna feature
multiple episodes of a dh mark hamill as
we see grogu's gradual
coming of age and i doubt they're gonna
recast luke skywalker since they've
already committed to saying
this is what luke looks like in this era
and ultimately folks grogu
is not gone forever from this series
he's gonna come back he's just too
valuable to the brand
and clearly they just needed to bring to
an end din jiren's assignment
so that now his relationship to the
child isn't just a work gig it's
a choice made out of pure love and then
on the other side of this after maybe a
time jump grogu will return to him most
likely without luke
and while grogu's midichlorian rich
blood may go on to produce clone strand
casts like snoke or a cloned palpatine
body via the sith eternal cult
grogu himself remains fully free to
sidestep everything that's gonna come in
the sequel trilogy he could join ahsoka
in the hunt for thrawn
he could reunite with others of the yoda
species and get an even sadder goodbye
like the character that most inspired
him e.t
but either way don't worry this kid did
not and will not
die at the hands of kylo ren as much as
kylo ren might have wanted to kill
something like that
[Music]
be sure to check out our great merch
options including a grogu shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at ea boss all in rockstar
subscribe to rockstars hit that
notification bell thank you for watching
i have spoken and you're winning
[Music]
you